okay so the the main reaction
to this especially from the left is if
we just had more laws
that somehow that would stop this stuff
now we have laws about murder we have
laws about shooting people we have laws
about breaking into people's homes and
attacking people and all sorts of things
but they seem to think just more laws
would stop this um here is adam
kinzinger who believe it or not is a
republican but he basically is a
democrat
and he's talking about raising the age
of the purchase of a firearm we just
raised the age of purchasing cigarettes
for god's sakes to 21. the age of buying
alcohol is 21. i think the age to buy a
gun should be 21. and people can come to
me with all the caveats about well they
can serve in the military i'll say the
same thing about drinking beer by the
way between the age of 18 and 21 but i
want to remind people that in the
military you have access to weapons but
the military deeply and and intensely
controls when you can have that weapon
when you can carry it and when you can
have ammo you don't get to take it home
and put it under your pillow so that's
really important for people to realize
okay i wanted to play this clip because
every now and again someone who i don't
agree with on anything says something
somewhat sane and the idea that you
can't vote but you can go to the
military we have these odd
inconsistencies 18 to do this 21 to do
this get a gun at 18 but can't buy a
beer i mean some of this makes
absolutely
no sense uh rav let me start with you on
this i mean the the odd inconsistencies
uh i know you're canadian but from an
american or give me from a canadian
perspective too i'm not even fully sure
on all of your age stuff there
yeah yeah the restrictions are much
different here for for drinking it's
um
i feel like i should know this but you
usually you don't follow these rules
when you're in high school i'll have my
guys check what's the age what's the age
limit on drinking in canada we'll get
that for you in a sec go ahead
um but no i i wanted to actually just
touch on one point quickly you said dave
earlier about like gun violence because
this has been the center piece of my
reporting it's like you have all these
laws in blue cities especially but we've
seen homicide rates rise exponentially
like in minneapolis they've risen like
30 percent uh in l.a st louis new york
city in philadelphia i reported last
year uh in 2020 there were more homicide
deaths than in homicide deaths combined
for 2014 and 2015. that there were more
homicide deaths last year in
philadelphia than two years combined
2014 and 15 and a lot of that was due to
the riots and defunding the police and
all these things that we should be
talking about we should be talking about
uh having a robust law enforcement
response i think it was ben shapiro who
retweeted this morning
that there was this new detail
that we i think we just found out that
there was no armed response to the
shooter for 12 full minutes after he
crashed his car
okay that's a conversation we should be
having about why that didn't happen we
should be looking at realistic solutions
and actually examining what happened
here and looking at the broader trend of
rising homicidal violence in inner city
communities rather than just
having these one-sided uh
narrow-minded political conversations
that i think the whole mainstream media
has plunged into yeah and i also think
we have to acknowledge without excusing
anyone who did anything wrong if any of
the officers there did not go in when
they should have and everything else
that there is no such thing as a perfect
system we don't know exactly when people
knew everything we always want the easy
answer like oh this should have happened
at exactly this moment and again that's
not to excuse anyone if anyone acted
negligently but there just aren't always
perfect answers rav just to let you know
in canada the drinking age is by
province so where you are in british
columbia it's 19 but it is 18 in quebec
and alberta just fyi if you're looking
to get a drink a little later um okay
sarah referencing i'm 21 i'm 21 so
that's good
but i don't think i was following that
in high school so anyway we don't we
should talk about that noted noted we
won't report you um sarah the this idea
of the 18 to 21 so kinzinger who i'm
sure you're no great fan of either
this idea that you can get a gun at 18
but you can't drink to 20 to 21 is
something worth talking about these
inconsistencies there uh but you earlier
mentioned what's happening with young
men and there obviously is something
happening with young men right now um
for many many cultural reasons do you
think there's any legitimacy to perhaps
raising that age from 18 to 21
well on the gun side i would say when
yeah yeah i would say that it uh
it becomes a slippery slope issue for me
that um i know what the left wants uh at
the end of the day i know what their end
game is and i think that the second
amendment is very clear even though it
can be uncomfortable at times i would
also argue that they really don't
believe these uh these ideas that people
are too young that that they're still
children that they don't need to have
some sort of uh you know a weapon
because at the end of the day these are
the same people who are weaponizing our
children who are
telling them that at three they can
change their gender so at three you're
supposed to have the the knowledge and
the foresight and the wisdom to know
what gender and sexuality you are but
somehow at 18 you're not old enough to
know how to use a gun properly so it's
just it's just the inconsistencies
coming from the other side that i get
very uncomfortable buying into the
conversation
again at the end of the day it has to be
a family issue right it's it's these
young men who this this young man was
failed at every level his family life
his friends
all of these people saw these signs and
no one did anything and i think at the
end of the day
your families have to be involved and i
know that that's not always going to
work perfectly as you said there's no
perfect system on either side
but
we can't be chipping away at a
fundamental right of this country
because it's gonna be a slippery slope
down to the bottom and we know what uh i
would call adam kinzinger basically the
left but we know what these people in
power want and that is ultimately
control they want to be the only ones
with the firearms and so it just it's i
agree with you that like if we were if
we were talking with uh a another party
who i believed to be coming from a a
morally sound place
i might be willing to have the
conversation but not with people who
think that you can change your gender at
two or three years old